and then even even like governments pay
out single mothers they don't pay out
single fathers
but don't you think that's something
that's something wrong with the system
because like I said previously when I
was when I was dating that like a person
who had two kids you know there were
times where he is a good father and
there were times where he would go into
the court like go to court and try and
you know get joint custody of his kids
and it would be so hard yes like that it
would be so difficult almost impossible
and it went on for years and and then
and then you hear and then you do hear
stories of women who go to court and
they do get that favor they do that's
but that's but that's the court system
that we currently have right yeah that's
what I'm saying it's like that's another
way women are bailed out of bad
decisions because they can leave break
up the home and they still get custody
and the chick and and a check any and
even and women owned two-thirds of
Consumer Debt right so we get homeless
what are their women's shelters
there's not really men's shelters like
that I mean there's like one or two but
not not the same way there's women's
shelters that's true I don't even know
what I don't know what the real time
like real-time data is for that in in
the UK If you're a woman and you have a
child out of wedlock and you're homeless
yeah you get Council house so quickly if
you're if you're a single dad they'll
tell you to get a job big man and sort
it out or your kids are going into kit
yeah you're not getting Council housed
like that yeah that's but I think that's
a massive flaw in again the system is
it's not a floor in the system because
the system is made for men to work in
order to put into the system and allow
women to cash out of the system so when
people talk about flaws it's not a flaw
it's how the system is going to work and
obviously as as Pearl has been saying
like
women are 80 of the consumer base so
they know it the system knows that if
men are working and putting into the
system the women are going to take the
money out and spend it on these luxuries
that you that women love you know bags
clothes and you know women are very
spontaneous with their spending do you
understand so and like when we talk
about for example the welfare state and
we talk about General double standards
this is not us as us as men advocating
that the double standards shouldn't
exist our problem is we accept these
double standards like no man who pays on
a first date is bothered unless you're a
broke guy and you're a loser and you
probably don't deserve [ __ ] anyway but
most men are not bothered but what our
problem is when a man now comes out and
says cheating for a man and woman is
different or then women just lose the
plot about it and then it becomes a
double standard conversation and that's
why when we talk about this is just that
okay women talk about how there's this
pay gap which is invisible it's just
because men do the harder jobs that get
most of the rewards so it's like women
choose to go to the education system
they're not blocked from going to the
education system most women achieve
better than men pretty much through
every single aspect of Education more
women go to university than men but who
becomes the corporate Bankers who
becomes the lawyers it's the men not the
women it's not because there's a window
there it's very simple with it's it's
risk versus reward due to harder job you
get paid more of the money do you think
that's because like women are expected
to
when once they have a child to stay at
home look after the child and they they
kind of
they have they have to you know lead a
certain lifestyle in order to support
their family I disagree with that yeah
well I'm just curious I'm just curious
why do we always say have to instead of
get to yeah you ever think about that
because it's a privilege to get to stay
home with your kids yeah definitely the
majority of women don't get to do that
it's like maybe 20 of women get to be
Housewives so unless you're in the top
20 of like hotness looks like whatever
you probably don't get to stay home you
probably have to work yeah so to me if
there's nothing getting in women's way
we got there's nothing stopping them if
they want to do it they do it yeah I
can't just be laughing like this day and
age you can choose to do that or not and
also with that like you have
um
women
essentially what do you they have it so
if a woman gets pregnant the man can
take
it's not uh paternity you can take
paternity yeah it's like six it's like
six weeks out if you're at a really good
firm whereas women it's like six to nine
months in the UK so like they're making
caveats to ensure that there's some form
of equality so it doesn't mean that a
woman has to take time off completely so
and I only going on what you're saying
and a lot of forward-thinking firms now
because of the whole gender neutral
lgbtq movement they've now made are you
get maternity and paternity but it's
shed so there's no it's not like oh the
man now only gets six weeks and women
only gets six months it's now shared you
get this amount of holiday
and then you get to pick that between
whoever
I think that's I think that's really
good
okay so we're gonna react to a video
um so pull up the one from the dating
show-ish
um you guys may have seen this clip this
went viral a couple weeks ago
I was actually reading um
I ship out interview in a few days so I
was just reading the artist strategy
okay
uh yeah so actually I'm a nuclear
physicist for the Navy yeah so I'll do
that in a few in a few days
oh yeah okay how about you
I am 27. I look a little young I'm not
that young
yeah so where do you live
uh so I'm actually in The Woodlands
Texas right now
um right right down there by Houston I'm
about 30 minutes away from Houston so
I'm a little close
um
where do I start uh
I like uh I like martial arts a lot I
did a bit of Pharmacy uh back when I was
a little bit younger about two or three
years ago I got certified at pharmacy
around when I was 17.
um I didn't really do anything with it I
went to University for a while I was
getting like a business degree so I have
a bachelor's in business and then I did
um Pharmacy for a little while for about
three years and then got bored so I was
like uh let's go see what the military
has to offer didn't do anything
um got my I did my pie chat about a year
ago got a 96 on that it goes up to a 99
got a 96. they offered me nuclear
physics and I was like why the [ __ ] not
so I went there and now I ship out in a
few days
oh okay nice well best of luck as you
ship out pineapples
you didn't tell me any qualities about
himself he's just like I made a 96 on
this I did this and I feel like I did
that at first too however I knew a man
with some personality you got that quick
you know you didn't have Personality
yeah it's not really good at reading
people okay well that's more the women
yeah okay so
so so so
I think that's the age thing though she
had a you she wouldn't think like that
she definitely doesn't have kids
no oh yeah yeah that's true right but so
my question is
again that's another like she's acting
like a child because she's putting like
personality and Vibes over the logical
thing which is this guy gonna be a good
husband
um what are your initial reactions when
we go around
um I felt like
um you could see that she wasn't
impressed she looked like she just
it was a bit bored
um and as you said as well I feel like
you could see that she's quite
young-minded and also you could see what
her preference really was just by even
the way she talked and how she looked
and not trying to be judgmental with
that but that's what I got from it
um the guy to me sounded very
intelligent and very had ambition and
you know seemed like a good guy